to unleash the potential of human beings
being able to talk freely with each
other Humanity will progress so much
faster so much better without the
federal government standing in the way
and having its boot on the neck of
America and the intelligence agencies
are getting a reckoning today Hallelujah
hell yeah I love to see it we need more
of it more than ever we are so excited
to sit in front of a bunch of
conservatives and say that well and get
Applause that's right I was screaming
about the FBI for like 15 years finally
you guys are seeing it thank goodness
thank you no no no no no George W Bush
George W Bush was like we need more war
we need more National Security we need
the Patriot Act I was like you guys are
crazy it's going to be used against you
guys what's happening right now it's
being used against you guys that's hang
on but that is why guys like yourselves
this platform Glenn Greenwald Matt Tibi
listen that used to be the Leading Edge
of the First Amendment and now we see
this is so dark and unbelievable the FBI
is taken with in the CIA in the DHS with
those Venture Capital firms that they're
very close to in Silicon Valley plus the
ones they've started up they control the
dialogue this is so obvious it's so in
your freaking face I think Steve you
said earlier that some change when
Kennedy got killed and I think what
happened was that the U.S there was a
revolution in the government to a
military government that wanted to set
up military bases all over Earth make
sure we circumvent world war three it
was the 1940s basically with the liberal
economic order and we're just now
recently kind of I'm starting to see it
this is like ancient Rome when the
Republic fell and the Empire came up the
elite legionnaires because you couldn't
take the legions into Rome itself but
they had a core of legionnaires called
the praetorian guard and the praterian
guard got into the business of selecting
the empress the ones we like are going
to be weak and we can control we're
going to put in power the strong ones
we're going to get rid of what the
administrative state in the Deep state
is is a modern praetorian guard and this
is an American Empire we we have an
obligation
left and right to come together and to
deconstruct the administrative state in
the only people we should be backing for
public office is those people that have
titanium balls right that will make this
their number one priority I'm not
running for office I'm not running for
office but he does have titanium balls
it was on my Wikipedia for a little
while so I have a question though about
Elon buying Twitter
when Elon initially tried to back out my
theory was he gets in to some of the
nitty gritty and sees national security
letters or some kind of government
roadblock something jamming up the
system and then he's like okay I can't
buy this but then of course they're like
no you have to buy it now I wonder if he
saw signs before buying it that this is
how bad it was I mean he just said that
on Twitter he said it was destined for
bankruptcy by May so but the FBI
involvement well of course I mean this
is this is what we're talking about
right so we talk tie together what you
know Luke is saying what Steve is saying
what's happening is that they are we are
unleashing with with the power of social
media with a power of communication for
us to be able to talk to have these
shows listen we are unleashing a second
flame of the Enlightenment throughout
the west and these frauds know they're
going to get deposed they know they're
going to get exposed they know they're
going to be seen and they know they're
going to be in all kinds of trouble for
the crimes that they've been committing
so Elon Musk steps into Twitter wants to
buy this thing and all of a sudden
they're like oh
we've been running a we've been running
a Scion yeah an active measure that's
right this is this is this isn't even
like controlled opposition kind of
language this is an active measure that
was being waged against the country and
what people don't understand is what
we're dealing with is literally called
unconventional warfare we're deep deep
into an unconventional War this is why
memes are so powerful as stupid as that
sounds because it disrupts I agree it
disrupts that's right but this is why
the FBI specifically went after memes
they went after satire exactly they went
after people who were making jokes
because they know that's and uh that's
al-basinski even talks about this when
it comes through but I want to add to
bannon's point really quick here because
I believe that the US intelligence had a
coup d'etat when they took out JFK 100
they had Vietnam they had the CIA dosing
people with acid they sparked the
cultural revolution some people think it
was the libertarian ideas that sparked
the revolution no it was too much
government doing too many things acting
too crazy acting like it was the emperor
that spurred to cultural revolution
which the intelligence agencies have
been writing on the back of with
promoting degeneracy trying to destroy
the family unit a part of their larger
depopulation agenda but that's just my
two cents a lot there it's 100 101 and
expanding an Empire we don't want an
Empire our Founders didn't want an
Empire we fought remember the British
Empire was just about to head to the top
of its game with India and the British
East India Company our Founders said we
don't want to be a part of that we don't
want an oligarchy running us and we
don't want to land an aristocracy
running us and we're prepared to go to
war and sacrifice Our Lives to do that
to fight that you know that's what we
have to do today because that's what
they've built and that's what they're
trying to protect one problem I'm having
is that the House of Representatives is
sort of an oligarchy unfortunately
they're bribable and I wonder if we
could build like a system of
decentralized you know smart contracts
where everyone could represent their
unit like all 700 000 of us from a
district could vote yes or no on
something and then that'll go to the
Senate we still have the Senate to veto
the crazy mob but do we really need this
vulnerability I'm on a roll and you're
going blockchain on me
no no no let me say no the founders set
it up so that the the House of
Representatives is always there we
should be winning House Seats we should
have dominant control of the house right
we should adopt and make it and make it
the weapon make it remember the founders
gave you the ability to taxes
Appropriations War all of it is with the
people they wanted that as the closest
thing in this Republic and everybody in
this audience left and right should come
together populist nationalists should
come together and say take a stand and
say no more we've seen what he did to
Kennedy to Nixon even now to Trump and
they're going to do it with it if Bernie
Sanders got in there they do the same
exact thing to Bernie Sanders this is a
little a little wild you know Ian and
Luke both bring up JFK but we just saw
that report from Tucker Carlson where he
said he talked to a source the cia's and
the CIA was involved they told him with
the assassination of JFK do you think
that they were involved with Robert
Kennedy's assassination also obviously
duh Luke's just like Let It All Out
do you trust the government Ian sorry
sorry I don't trust anybody Luke that's
why I want to decide that's why I like
smart contracts because if we're voting
for ours if we're representing ourselves
we don't have to rely on one guy to tell
tell someone what 700 000 of us think it
doesn't make sense I don't trust that
guy
speak up so we got a silent moment I can
go deep into some weird philosophy thing
instead of like this
specific crap I don't understand
so I want more abstract no I do I want
to talk about what Steve just said
because I don't think enough Americans
understand what America is about we can
talk about voting schemes and you know
policy [ __ ] and all this we want all we
want I don't think most Americans
understand what America is about and
Steve actually just touched on it and
the key thing is that America is founded
on a single important key principle is
that not one of us is God yes that's the
key principle of this country so what
that means if we're not God
true Authority lies in God whether you
believe in God or not you take it as a
symbol or as a literal thing doesn't
matter true Authority lies in God you're
not God therefore you don't have any
true authority over any other man and
now we have our Anarchist friend like
nodding along of course therefore what
are we going to do we're going to set up
a system where we lend political
Authority with restrictions with time
limits with all kinds of uh
balanced divided Powers so that they
can't run amok so that we don't become
an Empire because we're not God it's
that simple and if you don't understand
the basis of this what's John Locke
what's he saying John Locke says well we
got to secure life liberty and property
why does he say that Thomas Jefferson
Echoes it in the Declaration life
liberty Pursuit of Happiness why do they
say this they say this because if they
can't kill you they can't lock you up
and they can't take your property then
they can't control how you think and
they can't control how you believe and
they can't control how you worship God
and that's what it means to be a free
human being but they can control the
food supply and the water sources and we
need to make sure that we have
decentralized food and water as well
obviously I mean then we're getting into
Kissinger oh my God I didn't realize you
know whoever controls the food controls
the region vote controls the the energy
controls the nation whoever controls the
money controls the world yeah yeah are
you uh do you believe in God are you
atheist I am an agnostic is the fancy
word of the day but but let me say this
I I rail against secularism all the time
and James and I had this conversation
yesterday and I think secularism is a
threat to the west but a much greater
threat than not believing in God is
believing you are God
and that is much more dangerous threat I
will be partners with any atheist or
agnostic even though I'm an Evangelical
bible-believing Christian to fight the
people that believe they are God because
that is a much greater threat than not
being sure if there is a God listen
that's the fight of the West that's the
that's the drama of the entire West
there's these three competing Reigns is
it the rain Realms there's reason
there's Faith then there's this people
who get to believe that they they think
they know everybody they're better
everybody better than everybody they
know everything they have the gnosis the
special knowledge the secret knowledge
the Revelation the plan for the universe
and they get to enact it on us we don't
get to enact our will because we are
stupid and don't know it those people
are the enemy and everybody who knows
that we're not those people are on the
same team well there's another there's
another layer to this that I wanted to
bring up because you know if you guys
don't believe in God you have to
understand the the very powerful people
in charge they believe in something
there's a reason they go to the Bohemian
Grove there's a reason they hang out
with uh Marina brovich and do Spirit
cooking there's a reason they hang out
with all these devil worshipers
satanists and they do horrible things on
private islands that we can't even speak
about on the show so there is a
spiritual war happening right now
whether you can deny it or not but
what's happening and it's here is is a
part of that war let's talk about young
people because what you're what you're
all basically saying is main character
syndrome which I think we're seeing a
lot of in Millennials and some gen Z
where people think nothing outside of me
matters I also think to a certain degree
we're seeing this in every generation
and and the way I see it manifest is
when police officers go to say say
there's a a knowledge's drag event in
Texas where they're explicitly engaging
in you know things inappropriate for
kids and I'm I'm talking about what we
just saw in San Antonio with with
simulated sodomy and things like that
there should be no question the police
would go in there and say hey you can't
do this but they're not willing to do it
and I think because even for these
police officers many are probably in
their 30s or a little older are like I'm
not getting involved they're gonna get
mad at me I'm gonna get yelled at so
it's not just main character syndrome
it's also I'm not going to risk myself
for whatever this is and if we don't
have a cohesive culture where people are
willing to stand up for each other then
it just falls apart or maybe it already
did I mean this is that unconventional
warfare this is what they do in
unconventional warfare they make these
provocations drag queens are a
provocation it's been an escalating
provocation first they're just dressing
up in kind of somewhat you know careful
dress with their clown makeup groomer
clowns or whatever reading stories next
thing you know Tim and I were talking
about this yesterday next thing you know
they're they're dancing they're grinding
they're sexual dancing they're twerking
the next thing you know they're doing
simulated sex acts in front of children
and at the every step of the way this is
what Tim was saying to me yesterday so
this is Tim's credit gets the credit for
this is every step of the way they're
saying no no no it's just this no no
it's just this escalate escalate
Escalade this is an unconventional
warfare tactic to provoke the goal you
guys remember George Floyd the goal is
to have drag Floyd
and I'm serious this is deadly serious
Dave Chappelle speaks about this all the
time especially when it comes to
addressing actors in drag but it even
goes bigger because Balenciaga was not
an accident what was happening there was
a deliberate escalation of the culture
war of them bragging how far they could
take it I agree I agree the West was
largely built on a Biblical principle
and James agrees on distinctions a
distinction between God and man a
distinction between man and nature a
distinction between adult and child the
Bible at its best is a book of
distinctions understanding your place in
the world America understood this it's
why we're the freest greatest country
ever to exist in the history of the
world everything the deconstructionists
are trying to do right now from Citizen
and police officer to rule of law versus
Anarchy is to destroy distinctions
especially when it comes to children
they do not believe that there should be
any different treatment when it comes to
Children sexually or biologically
medically they must destroy the
distinctions this is part of their
theological really screwed up view what
is the defender of a distinction a
courageous citizen it's up for us to say
no no we are going to have the
distinction between an adult and a child
we are going to have the distinction
between God and man we are going to have
a distinction
in fact that's what keeps us free it is
the distinction I want to say one thing
to James you said the credit goes to me
I disagree
when the drag queen Story Hour stuff
started everyone started saying hey this
is grooming and the immediate defense
from the left was no no they're just
reading books and you'd come out and
you'd say yeah but drag queen
performances are removal of clothes
accepting of cash on stage he's very
akin to bikini bars or stripping and
they say it's just reading a book then
they started doing all they just drag
dance shows and they say it's just
dancing it's just dancing and that's how
they move you increment by increment to
the point now where we saw in I think it
was San Antonio where they actually had
exposed fake breasts in front of
children they had men simulating sodomy
and then the craziest thing is there's a
journalist on Twitter right now arguing
with I think Taylor Hansen's name saying
uh or is it Tyler I don't Taylor saying
um it didn't happen you edited it's a
fake video despite the fact there's a
dozen of them now they're moving into
denial the craziest thing about this and
I want to give a shout out to project
Veritas when they did and give project
Veritas money I mean that because they
they're a non-profit and they rely on uh
everyone's support for doing this when
they put out this video from Chicago
where the D of students is talking about
Kink education for children in a skirt
Francis Parker school I'm getting from
the people I know on the left are saying
but Tim it's just sex ed and I'm like no
no hold on it's just teaching children
about reproduction when you think it's
appropriate for them is very different
from teaching them how to lube something
for Kink that is something totally
different and that's what we're seeing
with these all ages drag shows I mean
that's why I made those podcasts back in
October November last year I called them
groomer schools and it's just been you
know I of course got blasted off of
Twitter for this uh back on Twitter
thanks Elon uh don't cuck this up now
um my gosh so here I am and I think
somebody backstage owes me money because
I said that but anyway
anyway what I did was I I've just been
proved right again and again and again
okay okay grammar okay grammar and the
goal is this again this escalating I
said unconventional warfare this is so
important I talked to Tim earlier this
year the first time I went on the show
this year with him I was like listen
political Warfare is the most important
concept you've never heard of
unconventional warfare political Warfare
this mid-level violence provocation is
so critical to understand because
they're giving you a choice they put a
drag queen oh it's just a story oh it's
just dancing and what you're going to do
is you're either going to give in at
which point they're going to enter into
their General generative themes
educational method into living clearly
strategic Defiance this is straight out
of their literature that they say is the
real goal of drag queen story we're
going to leave a trail of glitter that
will never come out of the carpets the
last sentence in that paper talking
about your kids brains
and then either you give into it and
they get to do that or you go too hard
and you you mess up and they make a
video of you looking bad and then they
start trying to smear you as an
anti-groomer or as rising anti-lgbt hey
this is the thought terminating cliche
so people don't think about it oh that's
bad don't think don't ask questions just
stop and say the person that's bad and
the goal is to get you to give in so
they get their way or overreact and
that's why I say drag Floyd is so
important to understand that they want a
drag queen to get attacked and they want
to make a huge amount of hay of it and
they want to create summer 2020 again
off of a drag queen or a trans person or
something like this meanwhile what are
they peppering the environment with this
is called in unconventional warfare
operational preparation of the of the
environment it used to be operational
preparation of the battlefield that's
why the intelligence Community is being
involved in this is so critical they
know this stuff and what are they doing
oh stochastic terrorism stochastic
terrorism stochastic terrorism everybody
who talks about this is a sarcastic
terrorist it's only a matter of time
until to lose violence and what do all
the Articles do they wrap it up they're
like oh James Lindsay Tim Poole Jack
busovic all these people they're saying
groomer Marjorie Taylor green saying
groomer Lauren bobert groomer these
people are going to cause violence
they're going to have their stochastic
terrorism and then what are they going
to do oh and Elon Musk let them all back
on Twitter so then they're gonna get
control back of the media so they can
keep control of the dialogue and of the
narrative do you see that there is a
strategy there is a plan they they have
a plan this can be beaten just by
calling it out ahead of time so they
look like jerks when they do it they're
going to try to get control well that's
the thing yeah of course of course and
they may or may not get it but if you
don't know that this is happening to you
you're standing in what they might call
the wizard circle with a spell cast on
you don't know how can you say they're
trying to get control They removed Trump
from Office no by the way by the way on
his watch with Twitter Twitter
specifically
Elon Musk they're going to blow out Elon
Musk that's what I'm saying a hundred
percent you think he's over there in
Qatar begging for money because I think
all the advertisers are cut him off he's
bleeding Cash He said today was it that
Twitter could be bankrupt by May or
Cincinnati it's been heading towards
bankruptcy bankruptcy Cincinnati heading
towards bankruptcy the thing's what
bleeding five or seven million dollars a
year a day a day excuse me they're in
control they're in control right now the
administrative State controls the
Federal Government it's far bigger and
in more parts of of our life than
anybody ever imagined and you know the
Leviathan and it's got to be confronted
we can't and he can't confront it with
half measures anymore
you have to take it on that's why you
got to choke it down and say hey we're
going to zero the FBI the FBI gets no
money whatsoever zero okay the
Department of Justice hallelujah
hallelujah and the ATF through the DEA I
know we're at the temple show with with
the great uh co-host but this is a
relatively conservative audience and
they're cheering to defund the FBI
because they understand the FBI is the
modern American gestapo defund
everything and the parks department
specifically I'm concerned about anyway
I just wanted to add one more one more
single point about because this latest
trip by Elon Musk is also very telling
with the Optics with him being seen with
Jared Kushner the guy who of course
lobbied against Trump's very populist
policies the guy who of course advocated
for the bombing of a sovereign country
and got it done the guy who of course
negotiated better weapons deals for
Saudi Arabia he was there with him so
that kind of brings up to the point what
Bannon was making here that there's a
possibility to that there is some bigger
money moves being made here well for
sure you said earlier Steve just a
minute ago that the administrative State
controls the government but I wonder
where they get their money the entire
government needs money the Federal
Reserve and where does the Federal
Reserve get their money they hit thing
they hit a thing and create it well they
get it from the Swiss franc the federal
the bank for international settlements
Swiss bank that deals out to all these
federal reserves around the world and so
we're basically being run by this global
banking cartel at the moment but
remotely not it's like remember the
Federal Reserve as the head of the
cartel Just Hits F9 and creates it okay
they just they are putting you everybody
in this audience under 35 years old is
nothing more than a Russian surf you
don't own anything and you're not going
to own anything you'll be happy you'll
be happy they give you a little bit of
credit and they put you on the wheel of
samsara like a hamster right you just
spend and you maybe get a little bit
more but right now even family formation
is later because it's tough it's tough
for a couple even to make it the the
they've taken what thirteen and a half
trillion dollars of net worth out of
this economy out of our middle class and
working class in the last nine months
the Federal Reserve here's the scam the
Federal Reserve just creates it just
creates it it's not backed by any bonds
they don't they can't sell bonds to
Japanese insurance companies or the
Chinese nobody buys it they create they
call monetize the debt that means it's
on your you're the full faith and credit
of the United States they create it and
the administrative State they'll take
all of it they can get how do you think
we got 31 trillion dollars on the on the
on the treasury nine trillion dollars on
the FED another 30 trillion dollars on
Social Security in in Medicaid and
another and contingent liabilities of a
hundred trillion dollars because the
administrative state has a funding
mechanism it's called the Federal
Reserve we have to End the Fed we should
not have
if you want freedom from the founding of
the country from the founding of the
country and to the founding of the
Federal Reserve almost the entire 19th
century was about populism in the fight
over currency in the definition of money
and who created it and they stopped that
because they realized the populist
movement was starting to get traction
with William Jennings Brian and others
right after after Andrew Jackson and
Lincoln being a national they said we
got to stop that okay the way they
stopped is the Federal Reserve we have
to to take down the administrative State
we have to grab the Federal Reserve by
the neck and choke it down right now
it's owned by do you understand your
currencies owned by 31 Banks 31 prime
Brokers owned the Federal Reserve create
it and make money off it and you live
like a pauper this can't happen we need
a revolution in this country and this
revolution's got to go this revolution's
got to go to the Railhead of where the
money is we've got to take control of
the Federal Reserve and choke down the
administrative State and anybody that's
not on that program is nothing more than
controlled up position can we we almost
had that and Tim you were on the front
lines of this and you talk about this
really well but let me just kind of hand
it off to you in a sec because I'd love
your thoughts the Occupy Movement saw it
correctly in one way and incorrectly in
another way Tea Party Movement was
happening almost simultaneously because
there was a series of decisions that
were made by Hank Paulson Timothy
Geithner Ben Bernanke all after the 08
crisis they could have allowed the
system to recorrect not put in all this
fake money but they made a decision and
they knew exactly what they were doing
modern monetary Theory baby 800 billion
dollars of stimulus which used to be a
lot of money and we're going to engage
in a decade-long sugar high and the only
way we're going to end is in a Currency
Reset Bernanke Hank Paulson Timothy
Geithner three former Goldman Sachs guys
by the way knew exactly what was
happening Tea Party Movement saw it
through a conservative lens too big of
government cut the taxes we don't like
it occupy sought through more of a
left-wing lens they're both seeing the
same thing said it differently Trump was
the only candidate to be able to
capitalize he might disagree Tim a
little bit a little bit so how did I end
up at Occupy Wall Street I was on 4chan
and there was something called operation
Empire State Rebellion which had nothing
to do with left or right it was
hacktivists and it was I don't know just
random people on 4chan who were saying
like hey you know we've got an issue
with what's going on with the big
bailouts our lives were being screwed
over the economy is in the gutter and so
that somehow merged with a handful of
leftists who were organizing some kind
of Occupy Wall Street when I go down
there for the first time I was there
within the first couple of days
there was nobody there there was a
handful of people standing in the rain
but that next weekend which was the
second weekend of occupy I saw old
people with American flags an old couple
sitting on a couch with an American flag
behind their about their back they said
they were conservatives we all saw many
Libertarians I met Luke done at Occupy
Wall Street the problem is
I think a lot of the people on the right
immediately assumed that it was like a
leftist liberal or something wrong and
so what happens that first weekend is
Big second weekend is bigger but people
who have jobs people who are
conservative and libertarian were like
I've got to leave and I've got to go
home and the only people who are able to
stick around were marxists trust fund
kids well off and to the left ended up
taking everything over well and so just
just to add on to this though so Trump
and Bernie Sanders ran the same type of
campaign simultaneously and because they
were both seeing the symptoms of this
sugar high money cycle of fewer and
fewer people getting really rich Bernie
came at it from an outright Marxist view
Trump came at it from a populist
nationalist View and Bernie Sanders
should have really been the nominee in
2016 but Hillary Clinton rigged the game
Trump became the nominee and obviously
won in a shocking fashion what we are
now living through 14 years later is the
economic catastrophe of Timothy geisner
and Ben Bernanke and Hank Paulson but
here's the thing and this is why James
his work is so incredible these
corporations think they are immune to
criticism and Revolution because they
have wokeness as a shield they have an
Iron Dome they think they are protected
from criticism because they can say men
can become pregnant white people are
evil wokism is the only thing they have
left protecting them from hundreds of
millions of people realizing that their
robber barons against the civilization
the first time I encountered the
wokeness whatever Occupy Wall Street
initially you know I'm down there and
I'm sure Luke has similar experiences
there's a lot of people who are just
economic populists they say I don't know
the two parties are bad whatever but
then all of a sudden these these
organizers started gaining more and more
traction who believed in the Progressive
stack and white men are evil there's a
good comic that embodies this and it's a
rich guy in a big chair with protesters
outside saying we are the 99 and he's on
the phone saying introduce them to
Identity politics all of a sudden
wokeness started taking over and then
from there I started I started seeing it
get bigger and bigger and you know what
for me I didn't think much of it other
than these people are weirdos despite
the fact that I remember one night there
was there was a a young black guy who
was watching all of this happen and I
overheard him say y'all are crazy you're
segregating people by race one of them I
don't have anything to do with this
occupy actually created their
organizational structure based around
your race they put all the black people
in one group all the Latinos all the
Asians yeah it was and and I wonder why
it fell apart no wonder yeah and then
over a period of time and there was the
upper class and the lower class divided
by two different areas of the park where
they were fighting and segregated to
their body parts and I truly do believe
I truly do believe that there was a
larger hijacking of this movement
because when it began there was people
doing weekly even sometimes in the
beginning daily walks and protests at
the Federal Reserve down in New York
City down on Wall Street they came down
there and they were like hey guys this
is not just about left or right this is
about the big Banks the banks that are
screwing us over the banks that are
robbing us of our wealth robbing us of
any potential future this is the
creature from Jekyll Island that came in
and is dominating and destroying our
society because what else could you say
that they did during 2008 other than a
blind robbery of the American people I
went up to Ben Bernanke and I asked them
how does it feel organizing one of the
largest bailouts in recorded human
history for all your Banker buddies
giving them trillions of dollars the SOB
tried to grab my microphone and rip it
away from me and he didn't say a word
then I asked him about the Bilderberg
Group he didn't want to talk about that
either no surprise there but but these
people are are criminals these people
are essentially people don't notice this
inflation is one of the biggest taxes
levied on the American people we are
going through essentially what is your
wealth being taken away from you every
single day by these banksters and unless
you're focusing on the big Banks you're
not focusing on the big problems it's
one big picture
I didn't mean to say hurry up I was
saying no no like it's no no no ESG I
mean this is right reset this connects
yeah this is everything if you this is
what you got to understand ESG is is a
tool so they can protect the banks by
creating a social credit system for the
corporations they all do the same thing
organized by the top Bankers that's
right that's right and what they learned
when Charlie brought up wokeness a
minute ago and gave me a very kind
compliment what he what you also don't
realize is the reason I do what I do is
because of the progressive stack as it
turns out it's a little funny I'll tell
you in a second biggest audience I've
ever had a chance to tell this story to
I get asked about it all the time but
what they learned in 2008 is that
wokeness works wokeness gives them a
sword and a shield at the same time that
they can wield that and protect
themselves they can go out and break up
a movement like occupy by bringing
identity politics and wokeness into it
and meanwhile look like the super
virtuous people who care about gay
people and have a rainbow on their on
their Shield this is what they learned
but it turns out by the way you brought
the progressive stack why am I studying
wokeness why did I dedicate my life to
studying this crap so I'm writing this
fake paper back in 2017 about education
I've told this story a few times how I
got there is another story
and I'm writing this paper and we we say
what we need to do is put a progressive
stack in all the classrooms what we've
got to do is we got to take all the kids
and the the college students if they're
adults and if they have we're going to
do the progressive stack walk or the
privilege Walk we're going to find out
the Privileges we're gonna we're gonna
chain them to the floor if they have too
much privilege we're going to make sure
that they suffer that they're abused
that they're put into the learning
environment of discomfort to overcome
their privilege and then we said but
we're going to do it compassionately
because we're writing funny hoax papers
that they didn't think they would accept
and the peer reviewers reviewed this
paper this is how gone Academia is they
reviewed this paper and said we love
this idea but you can't use compassion
because that would re-center the needs
of the privileged you have to focus on
more discomfort the pedagogy of
discomfort from this woman Megan Buller
which we hadn't heard of at the time so
we get this book and read it it's called
feeling power it's insane and I was like
holy crap this is where I mean this is
this is a this isn't just crazy this is
a genocide in the making down the road
if you are saying that you're going to
abuse people out of their privilege
score them by their abuse them out of
their privilege and you must use
discomfort and no compassion once you've
been identified as privileged this is a
danger so I said maybe I was wrong about
that I'm not claiming that's what it is
that was my thought and I thought I have
to study this for the rest of my life
and expose this and what Charlie said is
why because wokeness is The Sword and
the shield that they have that allows
them to protect it's the last thing they
have that allows them to keep this
criminal front girl going I want to
break up one point to what Charlie said
because I'm very happy you brought up
Occupy Wall Street because uh Occupy
Wall Street I do believe scared the
establishment I do believe the movement
was hijacked but that's one thing that
changed another thing that changed was
the way that the corporate media had
their conversations and we saw a very
big rise with organizations like the New
York Times start implementing a lot of
their woke policies right after Occupy
Wall Street because what better way to
divide and conquer a population that of
course have them in fighting against
each other so they don't truly see the
true source of their problems and that's
exactly what happened they want
Americans fighting each other that's
right they want you hating each other
they want you divided they want you
angry they want you pissed off and the
best way to not engage is to not play
along with their bullcrap so the
challenge is for us were anti-woke you
know we say hey don't divide People
based on race or these these immutable
characters let's let's let people be who
their character their Merit Etc
but now the battle is that that's the
division Luke it's the people who want
to divide versus the people who don't
want to divide creating this weird
division and they brand themselves as
Unity wouldn't that wouldn't that would
they just be perfect right well so my
question for you James I guess is if
this is their sword and their Shield
does it end by just collapsing in front
of them or does it what does it become
is there a way that the establishment
successfully wields this to their
advantage in the end well I mean I think
wokeness is actually now turning to
their disadvantage people are seeing it
has been exposed people are getting
upset I told some of my friends and
colleagues back in 2019 that if they
ever went full into the queer Theory so
unleash the drag queens that they had
shot themselves in the head it's only a
matter of time until thing Falls over
people aren't going to put up with that
for very long they're gonna and it
doesn't mean that you have to go do
something in in in you know something
crazy it's not what I mean by saying
that people aren't going to put up with
it they're going to see through that
this is fake this is fake so then what
happens we start to have these media
Awards they start Banning people off
everything that they're doing is
actually just kind of this accumulation
of weight that's causing that thing to
fall down so they have this sword in the
shield but it's getting dull The Shield
is getting soft and eventually we're
going to hit a critical mass and that's
how it always works that's why Steve's
always pointing to you and saying that
you're the solution that you're the
answer that you are uh what's your word
for it Steve the the you always call him
the the
I thought praetorian guard that's wrong
oh the force multiplier the force
multiplier yeah yeah no it's look the
big their biggest fear right now is that
you come to conferences like this you
get smarter and not just that it's
applied knowledge the reason they're
trying to take out everybody and
de-platform everybody and stop it all
and take you know go after Tucker and go
after everybody is because they fear you
that's right they understand they
haven't had a true populist Uprising in
this country in its history right not a
true populist Uprising the only way to
defeat it is a populist Uprising and
that is you so one of the ways I think
that it's going to
be exploited
is
economic marxists on the left
when they start to realize the people
they were indoctrinated to hate are
actually running the political party
that they're affiliated with when that
is exploited all of a sudden there will
be a massive Schism on the American left
wokism and people that are legitimate
Bolsheviks that believe in the economics
of Marxism but are not as enthused on
the race Marxist stuff that is going to
be a Schism because the vast majority of
Americans see that it's harder than ever
to buy a home that Consumer Debt is
increasing that your money is becoming
worthless those messages are going to
resonate like wildfire in the coming
months the coming years especially as
now I think we're going to hit a mass
unemployment cycle what's less and less
popular is hearing about privilege walks
or hearing about pan-trans awareness day
or drag queen Story Hour again wokism is
a smoke screen grenade it is trying to
confuse you it's a shock bang grenade to
try to say I don't know what direction
things are as soon as the the economics
of this will hit everybody's pocket put
in the coming months that's why they're
so afraid trade they're afraid that the
woke ideas are becoming largely
unpopular and that the economic reality
that's about to set in is going to unite
almost everybody on the right on the
left to point at the uniparty and say
you've been stealing from us for the
last couple decades and I'm not okay
with that and disenfranchising us from
our own country yes disenfranchising us
from our own country that's so important
to understand that we're being
disenfranchised from our own country but
do you think James that's this economic
crisis will overcome the cult mentality
that exists amongst so many of these
people on the left I mean people don't
just shake out of Cults man I mean
that's Leon festinger right he
infiltrates the UFO call the UFO doesn't
come what a big surprise or no UFO and
then what do people do they say well it
came spiritually and like turned around
because I mean this is so the people who
are are fully brainwashed by this that
they are they need help and I mean it's
really not going to be good for them
what will happen though is that most of
the people that are supporting it most
of the people that are putting their
black Square on their profile or
whatever
aren't that committed they're not
actually fully bought into the cult
they're confused and when things start
to shake they're going to start to see
that this isn't what they thought it was
and a lot of them will start to come
back to reality when you break the
active measure when you break the psyop
when you turn off the television
people's brains start to readjust to the
reality in front of them and this starts
to happen when reality shocks them back
most of them and enough for the key word
I said earlier is a critical mass of
people that's where you're going to get
this this Uprising Steve's talking about
this is when you have a critical mass of
people who say nope no more then it's
going to be everything's going to start
to change and it's going to change very
quickly we have to keep pressing to get
to that point we have to keep making it
more clear with to see through the smoke
grenade that the flashbang you have to
keep doing this but wokeness is an
increasing liability for them and
because of people like you it's going to
keep being an increasing liability for
them and they're not going to be able
they're going to try to get rid of it as
hard as they can when it gets to that
point but James it's it's not the TV
anymore it's big Tech social
I'm trying to make a bigger statement
here because just a few days ago we
finally got the receipts that it was the
intelligence agencies that were pretty
much controlling big Tech social media
oh yeah I don't think this is something
new I think this was happening for a
very long time and when you're able to
shape social media you're able to shape
the minds of the people oh yeah and this
is why since uh the onset of Barack
Obama I was like this is the beginning
of a larger divide and conquer agenda we
saw the destruction of Occupy Wall
Street we've seen the rhetoric change on
of course the the mainstream media but
on social media it was left versus right
black versus white old versus old old
versus young male versus female we we
saw this weaponized in Echo Chambers we
saw this weaponized with algorithms and
I do believe that intelligence agencies
had a play on this engineering this
larger conflict where we are right now
talking about pronouns and genders
rather than holy crap there's not going
to be enough money to pay for heat or
food soon so that's an issue that I
think really needs to be honed into the
Open Secret in Silicon Valley is the
social media companies are almost in
possible to make profitable because of
the server costs and the staff costs so
the question that needs to be answered
is did the intelligence agencies enter
during the Venture round of Facebook I I
think so electricity with q and tell
especially with a lot of the other
organizations that invested a lot of the
money there especially when it came to
alphabet and Google getting all those
contracts getting all those lucrative
deals getting all those tax incentives
get all get all that money back they
unfairly were able to go to the top
because they were connected with all the
intelligence agencies that brought them
there it wasn't an accident I this is a
question I had about Twitter that I was
was mentioning early on with Elon Musk
did he see government involvement and
then say Oh No but the bigger question
then when we start realizing with the
Twitter leaks of Twitter files that the
FBI actually paid to Twitter now granted
it was like 3.8 million or something
what is that like no no no no no but you
got to count the vaccine advertisements
you got to count Go Army ads you got to
count all the federal government Capital
rights because they'll bundle those
together that's hundreds of millions of
dollars but so so here's the point I
wanted to make the other day it was Elon
who responded to Ian miles Chong who
said in order for Twitter to be
profitable it has to become a platform
for creators of video and writing and
Elon said something like true
and I say no that's not true I'm sorry I
mean it's somewhat true you do need to
have a good platform that people can use
you can monetize but uh right now we're
not only in this convention center we're
on YouTube YouTube subsidized YouTube
the the cost of live streaming this show
we could never make enough money off the
show to actually pay for it
so it's a weird Circ it's a weird
situation where the big Tech social
media companies are subsidized and I've
always wondered where does that money
come from there is a theory of remember
when Facebook went public and they had
this meteoric crash I mean were they
trying to make certain investors
disappear in a public market of an
exchange and it didn't exactly go right
interesting so you you think I'm not
thinking I'm just asking a question it
was the most fumbled IPO in modern
history and you gotta Wonder that's also
the company that is probably in bed with
every intelligence agency and it was an
IPO that didn't just miss by ten dollars
you remember it's supposed to debut at
like fifty dollars a share right and
crater to 18 we're like what happened I
wonder why they have the best banks
doing their IPO right remember
the creation of these companies
come out of the top engineering schools
in the country right the the top
Engineers the top computer scientists
you know at Stanford at MIT and yeah
all of those universities are
essentially adjuncts to the National
Security State okay they're all
underwritten the university today are
virtually underwritten by the US
government and federal funds almost all
of that is tied back to some sort of
National Security State so the engineers
themselves the engineering has all been
underwritten when these things first
start the Venture Capital companies that
put in the hedge fund companies most of
these have strong relationships to the
federal government in the National
Security State okay this is all a p one
piece of a whole cloth okay and then you
talk about the contracts and how the
revenue goes and all that it all comes
through either the biomedical Security
State or the National Security medical
state which we or state which we've kind
of seen the convergence of during the
CCP covid-19 virus right so this these
are all adjuncts and by the way Facebook
is going to be
10 times or 20 times worse than Twitter
okay because the platform's bigger
you're going to see more and more
involvement you're going to see more and
more involvement in this they actually
say that the people there in in in
Dorsey that this was a
government-controlled operation
Twitter is a crime scene and it is an
intelligence op okay from day one from
the core of its being at the very
engineering schools where it started and
it's that's what I'm saying the
administrative state to to break this to
take this out root and branch is a 10 20
or 30 year project where you're on it
every day okay because it's taken them
since essentially World War II right to
build the National Security State and
this is not going to be easy but it's
everywhere right and it's particularly
in our universities that's why the
universities the the rail heads of
wokeness right now right the great
universities of the University of Texas
of you can look at Arizona State right
here all right these are the rail heads
of wokeness why because they're living
off government money they're adjuncts
they're just they're just Outpost
they're the new weapons Labs of Sandia
and Lawrence Livermore right the old
nuclear power weapons Labs the new
weapons labs are social media weapons
created by these universities in
conjunction with the National Security
in the biomedical Security State so we
saw that video from Project Veritas a
while back this uh this employee saying
I work what four hours a week he's
getting paid six figures we see Elon
Musk come in and he's like these people
are doing nothing and they're getting
paid all this money and I think about
that and I think about uh this this old
thing that I read where the reason why
there's so many people named Smith is
because when wars were breaking out the
blacksmiths were spared the war they
wouldn't go fight and if they were
captured they'd be spared because they
can make weapons the people who made the
weapons were extremely valuable and the
and the Kings and the rulers would keep
them comfortable so they could keep
producing powerful tools for them then
you look at these big tech companies
completely overpaid with money who knows
where it comes from they barely work why
they're making the modern weapons well
uh we should take a quick step back and
say well why why would they do this
right the weapons why are we making
social media weapons turns out this
thing Charlie was talking about a minute
ago my favorite paper criticizing what's
called social emotional learning which
is this whole brainwashing program the
left is replacing education with that's
a can of worms we don't have to get into
right now but there's this paper that
criticizes it from the left it's my
favorite paper that criticizes SEL is a
paper written from an old school
critical Marxist and so what he writes
is that the purpose of this kind of
narrative control he calls the paper uh
psycho data and what you are most
valuable what's most valuable about you
to this regime is your data why because
they can control you with it we don't
need a dollar back by gold or oil we
could have a dollar backed by you giving
them something that's very valuable to
them which is the data used to control
you so he says that they're we're
talking about the algorithms not just TV
right the algorithms on your social
media they can feed you they can nudge
you with what they call nudge Theory how
you're supposed to think how you're
supposed to feel the goal of this entire
operation with social media is to create
the environment in which they can do
this psychological pushing nudging of
you into different kinds of decision
trees that you might not have taken
otherwise so they can control you and
this guy guy Ben Williamson he's a
leftist writes his paper saying the
social emotional learning program in
schools this is what this is for it's to
gather massive amounts of data it's to
use this data to control people to make
them perfectly predictable economic
consumers perfectly controllable uh
political subjects and to control
everybody basically completely all the
time at the level of what he calls a
psychocracy a government through their
psychology so they think they're
thinking for themselves but they're
thinking what the algorithm taught them
to think and you therefore don't even
have freedom of thought this is his fear
of what this is this is what this is for
this is the kind of weapon that they
want to build this is a left-wing
critique like Charlie was predicting
would be coming down the pike and what
he says is that this is horrible and
it's awful and we have to watch out this
is a leftist saying this and then what
does he point to he said well where does
this come from who's funding and he's
like well we need to go through it's
very easy the world economic forum is
funding it the United Nations behind it
the World Bank is at the dead center of
all of it you can all of the players
we're always talking about are the
people that are behind this huge push
whether it's through social emotional
learning in the schools whether it's
through the algaocracy of government by
algorithm through the social media and
this is again we come back to Elon all
of a sudden he's going to he's just this
dude he's a rocket guy he's gonna go
rocket man is going to kicks Elon or
kicks Elton John off of Twitter or
whatever uh rocket man comes in and uh
he's gonna go build new algorithms that
are fun and he has jokes and he wants
memes and he's going to build these
algorithms that are not under their
control and they freak out but we had a
I think it was Phil Labonte was on the
show and he made a good point he said
with Nora link there is going to be a
chip in your brain that gives you the
tiniest dopamine hit that you don't even
realize when you when you're nudged just
in the right direction so you're a
regular person living a normal life
they're not going to come out and say
get rid of all your stuff oh nothing
you're just gonna sell something for
cash and it's gonna feel good and before
you realize it they're they're pushing
everybody with this control with this
chip maybe it's a little far-fetched to
say just right now but that's the fear
how is that any different than scrolling
through Instagram though yeah exactly
exactly you get your hearts on your
thing right you got a heart
that's right and Van life remember that
big trend on YouTube Van life where
they're promoting all these these these
young couples who were that poor girl
died doing that Gabby's something yeah
there was a uh article that we read
about a woman who said I retired at 36
and then when you read it you realize
one she didn't actually retire she's
still working and two she lives in a van
or she's traveling on a nomadic
lifestyle yeah when people think of
retiring they think of they had a family
they have a house they have a front yard
or something at least to that effect
it's about social engineering so people
accept their slavery because throughout
human history there there always was
some kind of despot or psychopath trying
to take over the world and I think the
really Smart Ones realized hey it takes
a lot of time and effort to to kill a
lot of people and I think in our modern
society what better way to take over
Society than of course have people
enslave themselves and I think that's
exactly what's happening right now and I
think bullets have been replaced with
tweets bombs have been replaced with
videos and right now we are being
engineered in fifth generational Warfare
in order to destroy the free human
spirit and that's the bigger fight
that's happening right now that people
need to realize more than ever and this
is why I always say violence doesn't
work because it's something they know
how to control it's something they know
how to manipulate they know that it
instills fear and is a weapon for them
that doesn't mean it's easy to combat it
just means you need to understand the
weapons they're using and it's
psychological manipulation yeah you make
better technology basically social media
is not a weapon on its face it's a
powerful force that can be weaponized
and it has been unfortunately by it
looks like alphabet meta Twitter these
things but mines for instance we've sit
around and have ethics conversations
with how addictive should we make this
technology it's 88 too much for me I
can't I don't want people constantly on
it I want them to use it for the
function that it's deserved and
uh you could have made it 100 I could
you could you can make it like an
addictive you make it 101 something that
someone's never even seen they didn't
it's more powerful than what you thought
could be the most addictive substance on
Earth it's not ethical we don't take
information at mines we don't want your
data because it can be it can be scraped
the key I think is open source code so
you know what the code is telling people
and uh you want access to your data and
you want to limit you want to opt in
when you want to opt in you don't want
them to harvest your metrics you're
basically saying power to the people and
I think people should own their their
own data and make money off of it let me
contribute some optimism though because
the neural link thing is real the
manipulation of people and and people
are looking for for Hope and one people
just screamed refereeing by the way
the next hour that's Ian's thing Ian's
thing is graphene sorry I wanna talk
about graphene
no I always wanted to say it's amazing
news that 50 million people didn't take
the MRNA Gene altering shot I mean that
goes to show there is a lot more love
and freedom out there and Liberty
despite the force the incentives the
subsidies the propaganda the nudging the
Hollywood celebrities the non-stop
propaganda campaign it was nothing but
difficult to not take that shot I mean
it was you had to go out of your way you
had to make an intentional decision and
still 50 million people made a decision
that this was not for me raise your hand
if you didn't take the shot
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look at this that's a big deal this is a
beginning of taking your country back do
you understand the pressure that was put
on there I'm telling you Your Heroes
this is freedom right here this is 1775.
you're Sam Adams you're John Hancock did
you guys see the article but no one here
took the shot right no not good enough
shot that's their language did you guys
see the article that said people who are
unvaccinated are more likely to get into
car accidents yes yes
I feel like that's got to be optimism
right like the narrative really is
broken where that's the best thing they
have I was gonna make a really bad joke
but I decided not to do it
no we love the cringe no but but but
here's oh I'm not gonna do that here's
the most powerful here's the most
powerful thing of it look at Robert F
Kennedy Jr and Dr Robert Malone and
McCullough in in in Naomi wolf these are
all people of the left these are some of
the most Progressive Naomi wolf was one
of the most Progressive feminist at Yale
when she was there she blocked me on
Twitter excuse me exactly recently or
after way back in the day for being
feminist fights yeah and we've had her
on the show this is my point this is a
coming together this is beyond politics
this is the New Politics right that that
you guys stood up you men and women in
particularly young men and women stood
up and refused to have that with all the
pressure all the society pressure all
the corporate pressure they brought
everything to Bear College their college
they were taking kids out of college for
not taking it but let me ask you about
this then it's I feel like it's only
possible because of the internet right
because social media allows us to have
these conversations to do shows like
this if if if these are really tools
that are crafted from the get-go by the
Machine by the by the intelligence
agencies are they well being used by US
you know what those are methodology you
know why we were able to do it
because in In This Crowd is handed down
the meaning of Liberty that's what it is
there's a kernel in this country that is
not prepared a kernel of in this country
is not prepared to be defeated and
you're seeing it that's why it's a pivot
point for us that's why we're ascended
that's why we're on the move and yes and
no matter how they de-platformed it
people got to that information right the
anarchists the revolutionaries everybody
got the information and we came together
and said [ __ ] you right
that's exactly right
is that the essence of Liberty yes
that's yeah hell yeah
what do you think what did John what it
what did Sam Adams tell the British
Empire [ __ ] you right what did John
Hancock say [ __ ] you USA USA
[Applause]
the underlying and by the way of every
ethnic every ethnicity in the Melting
Pot we are it is a common thing we
believe in Liberty and freedom and at
the end of the day there's a portion of
people that will sit there in the
cussedness and grit of the American
experience and say no we're not going to
do that we're going to do this okay and
that this is the beginning of the
counter Revolution that's why I'm
wondering Steve you and all you guys I
wonder what you think about this can we
ethically default on the debt to the
Federal Reserve
just say we're not paying you back 100
would that destroy our standing across
the world certainly wouldn't that we
have to force a sovereign by the way if
you're not going to force a sovereign
debt crisis you guys are going to be
more serious you've got to be able to
stop at the debt ceiling next year 2023
are going to be massive fights on the
biomedical Security State yes on on on
the economy on debt on are you prepared
remember it's not that they have to have
you accept slavery they have to have you
continue to vote and want slavery right
that's what 2023 is going to be about
we've beaten them and the one thing they
wanted to do was the biomedical Security
State and yes if we didn't have the
internet and most people curious the
Curiosity of people to get to hard
things like finding your show finding a
turning point USA when we broom from
everywhere finding you when you're off
Twitter people found that information
and they acted upon that information
that's the beginning of a revolution
that's the beginning that's 1773 baby I
want to I want to reiterate this though
Pfizer AstraZeneca Twitter CDC fauci you
have to understand how demoralized they
are that they could not get to 95 or 99
submission yes let's invert all of this
right people say Charlie show me some
good news show me some good news they
spent hundreds of billions of dollars
they forced every major institution they
took over the military they took over
the colleges they took over every
Fortune 100 business they stigmatized
you they smeared you they slandered you
they propagandized you they ran
commercials during football games they
did NFL athletes NBA athletes and still
they had to go to their room and they
said 50 million people are not going to
listen to us even if we force them kick
them out of jail or pay them and some
cities pay you to do it do you remember
when uh was it de Blasio eating the
french fries and the cheeseburger and he
was like this sure is good you just
gotta go I remember I saw a a prominent
celebrity saying that he went down to a
local parking lot pulled in his car and
got a shot in the arm and I I was
surprised I said he tweeted something
like go get the vaccine and I said no no
go talk to your doctor go talk to your
doctor from someone you trust medically
who's going to give you some advice and
the response I got from these people was
don't and so this is the big thing with
YouTube right they tell you you can't
give advice your podcast and I'm like
I'm totally cool with that if you got a
doctor who doesn't know anything about
your health don't that's a bad doctor go
find a good one I found a good one Joe
Rogan did but I'm seeing these leftists
pull into parking lots at 7-Eleven have
a guy reaching their car and they were
bragging about it they told me I was
wrong when I said and I just talked to a
doctor don't go to a parking lot at a
7-Eleven and and this guy actually said
I just stuck my arm out the window and
he injected me and I said shouldn't you
have a doctor tell you this stuff but
but it's the craziest thing to me that
like the the whole thing about Joe Rogan
is that Joe Rogan's saying go find a
doctor's going to prescribe this and
they say Joe Rogan's giving medical
misinformation hey dude you know what
man if you want to go into a parking lot
you live your life you do your thing but
my recommendation is a doctor who knows
about let me just prove one more thing I
do this in a lot of events and the
biomedical Pharma state will never ever
show it raise your hand if you know
someone who died or had a significant
side effect because the vaccine raise
your hand yeah right there that's an
open-air crime scene
forget I mean that and they say oh it's
small it's this you're talking about
millions and millions and millions of
people and yet you weren't even allowed
to mention that major so well I I
believe you know the shot was either an
IQ test or a compliance test or both to
be honest with you and we have to we
have to shout out individuals like Kyrie
Irving Aaron Rodgers stood up and said
enough is enough amen no my body my
freaking choice you were singing that
all along for years but now you're gonna
you're gonna kick that in the in the
bucket that made absolutely no sense at
all and truly they tried to take away
their Banks they tried to take away
their livelihoods they try to take away
their salaries they tried to take
everything away from these individuals
and they still stood up and made the
right decisions not just for themselves
but for everyone else who knew that they
were not alone in this bigger fight of
consent that the government wanted you
to bend the knee down allow me to be a
bit of a milk toast fence sitter here
and say my concern is not whether or not
um necessarily
well let me phrase it this way I don't
want to conflate government overreach
with advice from a doctor necessarily
certainly there are circumstances where
we can look at the corporate press and
they're all brought to you by Pfizer
brought to you by Pfizer and we have to
ask questions about whether or not we're
getting real real advice or if the media
is just saying we don't want to piss off
our advertisers but I think there's a
distinction to be made between what
really bothers me is when you're forced
to do something with with ridiculous
mandates unconstitutional mandates when
they when they threaten to shut down
your churches when they threaten to take
away your food or they try and entice
you with Krispy Kremes I just want to
make that distinction I guess well I
just I'll agree in the sense of if the
vaccine is so great and their ideas were
so great then why did it have to be
mandatory it would have just been this
amazing thing that everyone would be
talking about you know that sounds like
Anarchist talk there that sounds like a
lot like voluntarianism just a heads up
there oh no it should be we're agreeing
way too much I don't want to I know this
is weird
it's great I also want to just say this
too because I know you know maybe with
this crowd people will disagree to an
Ascent to an extent I think the the
reason so many people probably raised
their hand to seeing adverse effects is
because because of the mandates when you
mandate everybody get four shots the
likelihood of adverse effects is going
to go up it's going to Skyrocket yeah
the reason that they're working on 3D
printing medicine is because they can
tailor it to your own body and you in
the future we will be having medicine
specifically for your own genetics and
to put a top-down medicine on a bunch of
people I think is complete it's
dangerous and maybe you could argue it's
Insanity at this point let me sorry go
ahead no no you know I want to ask you
guys a moral ethical question because
I've been kind of harping on this for a
little bit
and I guess I'll ask everybody in the
audience too because I'm curious your
thoughts if there was a kid who had
let's say bacterial meningitis and the
doctor prescribed antibiotic
and the and the parents the parents both
came and said we don't believe in this
you know this Weird Science mumbo jumbo
so we're not going to give this to our
kid should the government intervene and
say we're giving the antibiotic to the
kid to save its life
no so you know the question is I would
have said yes but but I would feel free
to decide I would say no because in the
simple sense of that question is do you
believe the government should mandate
medication for you and the answer for me
to that is always hell no because the
government will use and abuse that power
in order to hurt people in order to
screw them over in order to make them
the guinea pigs of this larger medical
mRNA experiment and if the government
was able to give that child that
medication they could give them the shot
they could give them whatever the hell
else they want and that's and that's
kind of my point my point is the the
moral lines that we draw as a society as
a culture in that
when you look at something like it's a
new medication it's only been out for a
couple years if that and the government
tries forcing it on people everybody
says no but when you look at something
as simple as an antibiotic for a
bacterial infection a lot of people are
going to say yes I know a lot of people
here said no and that's fine it's never
that simple with government because
because again the gene pool will figure
itself out like people want to make some
mistakes they'll make some mistakes but
when you give the government that power
and authority to inject something into
your body they will take that and they
will abuse it to the fullest extent and
they have done it before they did it
with the testing experiments they dig it
they did it with the CIA dosing people
with acid they did it in so many
different ways when it came to poisoning
people screwing them over all in the
name of science doing what's best for
everyone else led to genocides and
atrocities that the human mind hasn't
can't even fathom right now what are
your thoughts James do you agree or
disagree I mean I'm genuinely going to
say that this is a complicated issue but
it goes back to the point I made earlier
about the mid-level violence the shot
was a mid-level provocation it makes
some sense to go get this vaccine thing
but it the other hand of course no it
doesn't and so it's not this obvious
case like we're talking about should
should we be allowable to you okay
somebody has a bacterial infection do we
take an antibiotic or whatever could we
have an expert panel of doctors or
whatever no death panels could we have
an extra panel of doctors say wait a
minute this was a completely reasonable
thing and therefore the state commanded
these are questions that healthy normal
societies that don't have parasitical
evil intented regimes running the thing
which is what he's warning us about it
will almost always become the case if
we're not very very very well but one
last Point really quickly look what big
Pharma did without that within the last
few years look at the opioid epidemic
look at the destruction of the American
middle class that was done through
doctors that was done by the medical
establishment that was paid off by these
sociopaths at Big Pharma that said you
know what we're going to Bunk the
science we're going to get you on heroin
we're going to get you baby heroin these
are evil sociopathics son of a [ __ ]
that don't give a damn about you never
gave a damn about you and we should
never concede and give them anything
ever and sometimes it seems to be the
thing that's the thing you can only have
that in a high trust Society you can
only have the thing that you're arguing
for Tim in a high trust society and we
didn't break the detonte on the trust
they did they violated us we have no
reason to trust them now we have we're
here from Luke everybody's cheering of
course they are because we've lost trust
in our society and that ladies and
gentlemen is on them
also I think it's inherent in the nature
we're not supposed to trust each other
we shouldn't have to the system should
we really shouldn't trust a bureaucracy
either that's extremely important in
this case like because just like Luke's
saying they're going to pay off doctors
they're going to get the this has become
the big you we talk about Twitter being
a crime scene we're looking at the
biggest crime scene in the entire world
maybe in the history of the world Tim
just to answer your question we have
thought to be realistic of what we're
living in so that would the parents I
think would make the wrong decision
there however let's be honest about
what's going to happen way more often
parents don't want to give their 11 year
old Lupron even though the doctor says
that the boy thinks he's a girl that's
really what's going on so hell no the
government should not be able to step in
and overrun parents right damn right
this is exactly I just want to make one
little Point here hold on hold on this
is my that's exactly my point right we
saw we saw Matt Walsh on Rogan's show
and he he was asked how many kids do you
think are getting this and I think he
said millions and then it turns out it
was in the thousands and we are seeing
an increase in this dramatically but the
more common occurrence is is antibiotics
and not luprona but that this is my
point exactly well no it's the same law
I think thousands of parents are
withholding antibiotics for their kids I
would argue that antibiotics are
prescribed to their kids more than
Lupron as is what I'm saying oh no no
for sure but I I don't think there's a
mass push of parents that are saying hey
your eight-year-old might die and I have
you know a deep-seated conviction that
somehow amoxicillin is against my view
like not doing the math on this guy no
no not crunching them no no my argument
is that the same law some people will
say oh right antibiotics that's a normal
thing oh Lupron that's a bad thing but
it's the exact same law and so the issue
is it's culture not law the law can say
a lot of things but if you have a group
of people who don't believe in morals
and ethics none of it matters the police
aren't going going to these drag queens
these drag uh these these uh simulated
sodomy shows like they're doing now in
San Antonio and they're not stopping it
because there's no cohesive culture
that's a problem the cops should no
question they should say we don't do
that but it's just not happening so I
just want to point out you guys are
agreeing with the anarchist well look at
me I'm a liberal
not YouTube or saying these guys right
here definitely you're agreeing with the
conservatives
you're an old want to make a bigger
point you all agree with James Lindsay
what the hell I just want to make one
point one point specifically here of
course you do now take this one example
and you implement it everywhere that's
Anarchy and that's what we need more of
in mind well what about okay so what
about if there's a disease that's like a
bad idea it's a great idea no for
example we need a border and a big wall
okay that is a function of government
that we need in welfare do you need
welfare very little minimum have Army
coming
so we were planning on having having our
meet Dylan come in when you're ready
yeah I'm gonna I've got to go do another
media unit Steve ladies and gentlemen
and everybody Steve anything you want to
say Steve before you go
one more give it one more if you yeah
just bring it Steve
you are not just the future you're the
present
if this country's to be saved it's
because of you what is your task and
your purpose if it's to wake up every
day and to save the greatest nation the
most powerful Nation on Earth this
nation will be saved that I guarantee
you but but if you don't and you falter
they're gonna win okay just remember
everything you just went through in this
vaccine I'm telling you it's a fantastic
win look and look at look at look at
everything pull all these people that
fought through Twitter crushing them
YouTube crushing them Facebook crushing
them and this is the American cussedness
to say guess what go [ __ ] yourself we're
gonna win
Steve Bannon
thank you Steve
it is an honor and a privilege thank you
Steve I I feel blessed and lucky for for
everybody who's here and uh we we are
going to have I think we have Harmony
Dylan coming out right yes which I I can
make an announcement while she comes out
everybody you guys have an email as an
attendee of America Fest that is a poll
of who you think should run the RNC
maybe Mike Lindell maybe Harmony Dylan
open up that email and vote don't yell
it out just vote brought to you by
turning point action oh oh we got
somebody coming up oh hell what is this
who is this oh my God
let's go I'm here to Smith harm me Dylan
I can already tell who it is I think I
think it's it's clear
even in the future you got 10 seconds
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Alex wait
I had two mics I could see him coming
and I knew it was him one James two mics
now I know how Dave Portnoy feels vote
in the straw poll everybody you got an
email I don't think Dave was actually
there though no no is the microphone he
break the mic I think the mic works
he just wanted to say how I caught it I
caught it he just wanted what did he
even say he wanted to sniff Charlie Kirk
you know while we're waiting for her
meet maybe we can do a little spiritual
Deep dive here really quick Charlie you
mentioned something earlier about um
separating God and man yes and the
Jewish the Bible the Old Testament says
the second commandment is no false Idols
you don't worship a human and then Jesus
comes along and he's a Jew and he agrees
with that because he's a Jew and then
the Catholic all of a sudden like 70
years after his death 35 years after his
death they tell people to start
worshiping him no that's not totally
true so we we believe that as Harmony
Dylan and harmony
it's Young
so this this works out sorry to
interrupt you guys but uh I really want
to answer that question though because
that's important so so we we were we
were thinking about uh you know Steve
had had a had uh I think another
conflict conflict and uh but I think
it's an opportunity to talk about
Solutions because we talk a lot about
problems we talk a lot about Hope but I
know that harmed is a potential solution
yeah you got to grab the mic I think
Alex Alex this still works I think it
does you're good it'll sound great hi I
will answer that question Ian we will
talk later all right okay because Jesus
is the way the truth and the life
harmeet what's happening
well it's been a pretty busy two-week
campaign for chair of the Republican
National Committee and so uh it's been
pretty non-stop we were just talking
about Jesus Christ and spirituality
right as you were walking out so there's
a lot of uh a lot of things happening
there's a lot of energy
Ian's had this transformation I was
telling people like we're all of a
sudden he's talking about the importance
of God do you believe in God absolutely
what do you think it is
uh well God is the creator
God is over all of us yeah we can't see
hermit's face lower that downwards there
oh and then uh do this yes God gives us
guidance God gives us life and God gives
us everything that's worth fighting for
in this country and this world
let's talk and just in the Christian
view just to answer your question so so
Jesus claimed he was God there is a
misconception that Jesus never did that
he repeated the phrase I am especially
the Book of John uh the first verse in
the Book of John is in the beginning was
the word the word uh became the Word was
God and the word became flesh this idea
the logos right which is rational speech
which is God made in the image of God
and Jesus coming down in human form was
he took the broken form that we became
after original sin because he loved us
so much to minister alongside of us to
show Miracles to then eventually die a
death he did not deserve to defeat death
so then he could be raised from the dead
and we can have eternal life now the
point is this when we worship Jesus
we're not worshiping man we're
worshiping God that temporarily became
man lived a perfect life and then gives
us eternal life through what he did for
us something we did not earn nor that we
deserve I'm concerned that a centralized
Authority uh wrote The Storybook that
tells us that he said he was God because
I don't I never met him I don't know no
that's that's fair but it's not a
centralized Authority because we have
four different accounts right from four
different people Matthew Mark Luke and
John right and so what's interesting is
they actually reinforce one another and
never contradict each other the one the
most interesting is actually Luke
because Luke continues his gospel in the
book of Acts and so Luke is writing it
to his benefactor Theophilus lover of
God who paid for him to actually go
throughout the Middle East and saw it
himself Luke was a Doctor Luke was a
non-committed person right he was like
there's something magical Happening Here
in the Middle East and so you're right
you've never met Jesus but my belief is
you can because he is the Living God
right so that you can invite him in your
life and in a moment you can have a
spiritual transformation don't mean to
hijack it too much Tim but that's my
that's my metaphysical View and Jesus
will change your life and you can be
transformed in an instant
let's talk about Solutions sorry let's
talk about Solutions because how meat is
running for RNC chair that's right so
what's going on what's the plan
well I don't think there is a plan
unless we have a change in leadership at
the RNC and that's the problem because
for the last six years
we have lost successively we've lost the
house we've lost the Senate we've lost
the White House and we're losing our
country and the reason that I'm a
republican volunteer and activist and
I'm sure many of you are in this room as
well is because I love this country I
came here as an immigrant when I was two
years old my parents registered as
Republicans when they were
naturalized and you know my whole life
I've fought for these values but I'm
afraid that we have a lot of Republicans
in positions of power today including
elected officials including certainly
some of my fellow Republican activists
who are in it for the wrong reasons who
are in it for ego who are in it for
self-gratification who are happy to be
the controlled failed opposition and
America cannot afford that and so that's
the reason why I'm running because I
think I can do a better job and I think
that we need Vision we need a plan
we need a plan to deal with these
crooked election laws we have to adapt
to overcome them and we need to get rid
of the corrupt consultant class that is
controlling the failure in our party I
pledge to do that at the RNC just really
quick what would you be doing different
right now your your your head right now
what's the first thing you do
well I probably hire some great young
Grassroots activists to handle the voter
registration ballot harvesting yes and
ballot curing and states where it's
legal Scott Pressler is one of the guys
who comes to mind for sure absolutely
the second thing I would do besides
Personnel I would I would do something
like an Elon Musk style come in and say
look are you hardcore about electing
Republicans yes are you hardcore about
Liberty are you hardcore about winning
and if you're not here's your two-week
severance check and don't let the door
hit you okay
um
I would immediately initiate a top to
bottom audit of all Consulting and
vendor contracts at the RNC because from
what I've seen there is a tremendous
amount of back scratching fat waste
self-dealing and generally stuff that
doesn't get Republicans elected so with
those two things that's off to a good
start but then there's policy there's
other things you have to do fundraising
is important we fundraise by abusing our
donors we call them names the puppy will
die if you don't give money
um you know if you don't give money this
person that you like won't get elected
and then we use it for different things
I think that's not ethical it's not
consistent with my values as an attorney
that would stop under me at the RNC
sounds great so this is so important
because what you have to understand is
when the left makes its moves you're
like oh the left the left the left when
the left makes its moves it's making
again I keep saying this word a
provocation when that becomes real is
when the conservatives are like okay
we accept we reify the thing that you
just wanted to do so you know they
passed some horrific policy and when
conservatives are like okay that's just
how it is now they change what it means
to have an election and conservative
that's just how it is now that's when it
becomes real that's when we've actually
given away a piece of our country so
having somebody that's going to get in
there and try to stand up and clean this
mess up this controlled opposition hell
half of them are probably active active
participants not controlled opposition
they're pretending at that point what
you have to be able to do is you have to
get in and get in the way of that
because it's those people accepting it
it's the Republicans rolling over after
Barack Obama passes uh Obamacare they
get in 16 Trump comes in on a mandate to
get rid of Obamacare what do they do
like we tried and then we're we're in
this swamp this is how it works we don't
lose our country until we give away the
peace that they tried to take from us
this is so important and this is why I'm
so enthusiastic about her meet and why
I'm enthusiastic for anyone that's going
to challenge the RNC Mike Lindell
included right and which is this is that
when you lose
you should not be rewarded I know that
sounds so obvious that's the way we
treat our football teams our
corporations or anything functioning and
we should have won the Senate this last
election cycle and the Democrats gained
a senate seat period Kerry Lake should
have received far more support from
National Republican organizations
and she did not and
look I I'm kind of a subject matter
expert here you know Turning Point USA
we're super blessed we have 150 000
donors many of you give us money and we
are good stewards of that money in fact
we have 100 rating from charity
Navigator and our our fundraising costs
are right near six percent the rnc's
fundraising cost is 40 percent so when
you give money to the Republican Party
only 60 percent goes to programming and
then I have to read they spent 321
thousand dollars on flowers they spent
17 million dollars on donor mementos a
hundred thousand dollars on clothing
like look we run an organization we run
a really tight ship that is unacceptable
for the Republican party to be doing
it's an insult to all of you that have
donated to candidates and change is
needed immediately and I think people
don't realize this stuff I mean I don't
know a lot about the inner workings of
the RNC or or the DNC it's only in the
past maybe I don't know half decade or
so we start learning more and more about
the inner workings and now a lot of the
stuff we're learning about what was
going on 300 Grand on
so let me let me unpack this so that
that shrieking sound you hear from the
building at the RNC is is a lot of
consultants and um staff there jumping
to the defense of the chair and I'm
going to give her the benefit of the
doubt she probably knew about some of
these things and thought okay this is
business as usual that's part of the
defense is hey everybody does it and
then part of it is done by her staff uh
and you know including some of these
Consultants who are making themselves
rich off of donor money big dollar and
small dollar donor money but if you're
so tone deaf that you don't realize that
seven hundred thousand dollars worth of
flowers over a six year period showing
up on your FEC report when the Democrats
spent one thousand dollars during that
time is problematic and you're defending
that you are totally out of touch okay
and and blaming Trump which is another
line of attack that happened out of the
RNC they said Well when the president is
of your party you pay for all the
mementos you pay for the Easter egg hunt
you pay for the Christmas parties
actually that's a separate line item
that's another five million dollars that
we haven't even talked about five
million dollars of parties and White
House stuff but 300 500 000 or 300 000
worth of the jet expenses happen after
Trump left office so how are you blaming
Trump for that a lot of the flowers a
lot of the limos 300 no 3 million
dollars worth of the donor mementos came
after Trump left office guess what guys
I'm a donor a lot of you are donors do
you want mementos or do you want us to
win elections
here's a question I have
in terms of winning these elections
how do you convince this guy to vote for
a Republican and I have a question
um add to this because Trump was just
brought up today he also officially
endorsed Kevin McCarthy as the head of
the head of the GOP another career
politician which as you can see from the
yeah keep going you don't have to stop
keep going let him hear it let him hear
it all right how do you guys deal with
with things like this how do you address
it what's your reaction to this kind of
latest news item well I'm going to say
something which is that if we had done
our job at the RNC and also the
leadership of the other two committees
and Republicans had a large majority in
the house we wouldn't be having this
conversation we wouldn't be having this
really awkward conversation about a
five-member margin the freedom caucus
some of them not being happy and this
even being a conversation we might have
been able to freely elect somebody who
was popular with all of the members but
because of this odd situation that if
they don't go that way a Democrat might
win I think that is sort of the the sort
of the only choice that Republicans have
right now Kevin McCarthy's better than a
Democrat
um and so he's from my state so I have
to be you know a little diplomatic uh
that's tough but but you know look I
would say through the years of the last
six years there have been a lot of bad
Personnel choices there's been a lot of
bad choices about who's around the hand
of power and here we are and so I think
we're going to make one more at the RNC
if we just say please sir may I have
some more losing yes I don't want that I
don't want another helping of losing
well and I just can I brag on harmeet I
hope you understand how difficult this
is for her to do she's a member of the
168. this is a club it's a cartel it's a
smoke-filled room you are not supposed
to ask questions and she is receiving
non-stop personal attacks on her
business and her family these people
have the knives out and it's a lot of
Courage for a person of the 168 to
challenge one of their own I think she
deserves a lot of credit for them thank
you but Charlie uh
the pain is being spread around because
while you've been sitting here a member
of the 168 made an attack on you what
did they say well you sent out this
email yes saying that Turning Point
action might remove members of the RNC
if they vote incorrectly yeah well
you're a bully oh I'm a bully you're a
bully that meets friends are bullying us
no this is why I kind of actually
question one of your premises I mean the
question the premise that I'm
questioning is that a republican who
sucks is better than a Democrat who you
you know you see is it's an obvious
enemy and so at this point it's like I
don't and I'm not saying that I have an
opinion on this but I'm actually more
worried about the Republican who poses
as somebody who's going to do the right
thing and then flops it every single
time than I am about the Democrat who we
you know we know they're going to do all
devil you know exactly you can mount a
clear opposition to that and we have to
be milk you know it's not my premise you
asked about Trump's endorsement no no
that's the premise that's why I know
that was him I don't know I'm I'm the
one who's being told that Rana has 107
votes so it's a feta complete I don't
accept that no I am not accepting it and
I am stepping up to challenge it and
guess what people are turning my way I
think that's me you know from from a
little bit of the earlier conversation
I I look people on the right call me a
liberal people on the left call me
conservative or far right and uh for for
someone like me probably Ian and Luke
we're not as easy to convince to vote
especially when we see constantly
McConnell or McCarthy or whatever
so I understand you don't want to lose
me I'm I'm more amicable too okay I get
it let's let's you know get our
incremental victories but winning over
more individuals like us to come to this
side is going to be very difficult if we
just keep saying the same thing over and
over well 100 and look I mean we
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing again and expecting a
different result and so
with with messaging that isn't working
certainly not appealing to young people
the idea that a member of the 168 would
attack the most popular youth movement
in America right now shows you how out
of touch they are but by the way all of
us don't feel that way what state I have
also is this person from Washington
State
um but yeah they're doing really well up
there that Republican party
super robust
honestly some of the members by the way
many of the members I've spoken to I got
a call each of them have hour-long
conversations which is wonderful I hear
from them a lot of them are saying
hermit and one of one of the things
they're upset about is that organically
thousands of Americans began contacting
them from their own State saying we'd
like change this offends some members of
the 168 they've said how dare you how
dare you sick this mob of low
information bitchers on us that's one
statement that was made in the media by
one of the members this is how this is
what the RNC thinks of you not all of
them but some of them well currently
they're saying it's a majority though
right what they're saying but but some
of them said harmeet I don't mind at all
I came from the Grassroots I love to
hear from the Grassroots we need the
Mount Vernon project to get more of
those leaders that's right yeah so today
Turning Point action we announced the
project if you're not going to represent
your voters at the RNC Turning Point
action will work to remove you I also
want to make a point here
you bullied
[Applause]
one point I wanted to make here to Tim's
question about how you how you get me to
vote is that I think the political lines
have broken Tim deals with the corporate
media attacking him from the left and
right I had Bill O'Reilly call me a
Jihad loving liberal I had Chris
Matthews call me a right-wing racist tea
bagger right now it's not left or right
it's establishment or anti-establishment
and there's a huge portion of this
country that doesn't vote doesn't
participate and if you could get those
people because those people are the
anti-establishment those people are sick
of the two-party duopoly they're sick of
being told lies every election cycle
only to be let down only to be promised
a bag of goods that gets taken away when
they get out of that voting box how do
you get the American people to care that
are anti-establishment that's a question
that I would love to hear from you guys
well one thing I would say is that I
will say that the something I've been
saying on the campaign Trail for the
last two weeks and for years actually is
that our party is not the party of the
Chamber of Commerce anymore and the war
mongers and it's not that party anymore
that was the party when I was young
Cold War era neocons everywhere running
the party but the people who run the
party some of the members of the 168
have actually been there since that era
and they haven't noticed that the voters
have changed they haven't noticed that
the Trump populism has brought a whole
new wave of people into the party yes
unless we
work to retain those by messages
messages and Messengers who believe that
who act that who tell them that we want
them we are going to continue to lose
elections just real quick probably
should have done this right off the bat
but can you explain the 168 yeah the 168
is like I was we were joking backstage
it's now sounding like the Illuminati
but the 168.
That's My love language
168 or three members of each of 50
states and six territories and believe
it or not my state with 40 million
people has the same amount of power at
the RNC as American Samoa they also have
three and they have like 50 000 people
there but those 168 vote to elect the
next chair of the RNC Treasurer co-chair
and so forth and so you got to get a
majority of them that's that's 85 to win
and so Rana started out with a you know
big list that list is smaller if we were
being truthful but people are being
attacked there was a story today that
she quote unquote lassoed somebody from
the herd who had flipped over to my side
got them back this is the kind of
humiliating language we see about this
election conservatives pounce it's
conservatives pounce is it because the
ones people at the 160 feel like they're
going to lose like deals that they have
if they're gonna lose like if I were if
I were in the new chair I would change
who's the chair of all the Committees
okay I would stop the tchotchkes uh at
donor expense I would stop the staff
Retreats at a thousand dollars a night I
think that's obscene I would stop a lot
of the ways to Nexus there I have
pledged to move most if not all of the
operations of the RNC out of DC because
DC is not America I'm sorry for anybody
who lives in DC and and I want people
who work at the RNC to live in America
and be in touch with America because we
represent America
and so it's very that's very threatening
to Consultants who live in America
lobbyists who have the pipeline to the
Consultants all of that so that they're
very upset about that two things so
first it's kind of similar to the
College of the Cardinals but it's a
secret ballot which is upsetting to me
but it's also really exciting to me
personally It's upsetting because I want
to be able to know who to hold
accountable but I think a lot of people
are going to flip on Rana are gonna and
vote for harmeet since it's a secret
ballot so I think it's it's actually I
think a better thing in some sense but
number two to answer the question of how
do you win over me I will just keep on
reiterating this we're a conservative
organization at Turning Point USA and we
allow different opinions and different
voices there is a trend that on the
right free speech is protected and
preserved show the equivalent left-wing
group that would invite Tim Poole to go
do his show and just kind of take
questions it just doesn't exist well
Luke's uh he's pro-biter Biden fetterman
you can tell by his shirt it's a
no-brainer he says no-brainer hey two
potatoes are better than one potato okay
if I speak in my language I I agree with
what you're saying though and and it's
it's that does that mean comic where
it's you know a guy in the middle and
there's a there's a blue person and a
red person the blue person pushes the
guy in the middle and the guy in the
right says oh are you okay and then
they're like why are you siding with the
right and I'm like clearly like if I
have discussions with people I fall on
the the more traditional liberal
Spectrum I'm sure James does on a lot of
issues as well but here why in a little
bit man I'm I know I'm less suing James
over to myself no no your lasses don't
work yeah there you go I have a
tremendous Integrity but they're
freaking me the hell out man the left is
out of control they're freaking me out
something that bothers me we mentioned
Insanity earlier Army doing the same
thing over and over again is that
recently we've been using digital voting
machines and the Italian the votes in
secret with proprietary code I think
that's unethical I think that the code
should be open source of course so that
we can watch the tallies and I'd like to
see a a backup of the voting on a
blockchain so that we can verify our
votes without having to rely on a
company telling us what our votes are
and the whole idea of these corporations
having proprietary access and they can't
show you the code because that would
break some NDA that's nonsense and we
must stop allowing that and think about
what this means too it means that there
was a period where we used paper ballots
that you could physically see and check
from a box and then one day without
anybody realizing it a private
Corporation got full control over that
knowledge and took it away from us is it
something that the RNC that you can
change
I can't change it at the RNC but the RNC
can strongly encourage certain policies
we can go to court and fight we didn't
do that for four to six years I've been
at the RNC I started I mean I'm a lawyer
so of course I started jumping up and
talking about that in the last two years
we began to do it Mark Elias and Company
were doing it a decade earlier they're
extremely well funded after the
Democrats didn't do well in the 2004
election they all had a meeting of their
Illuminati okay they sat around a table
and it's okay if Bob Chuck Jim Sue each
of you is going to give hundreds of
thousands of dollars for the following
200 non-profits non-profits okay and
then we're going to use that to control
America's elections and it took them a
while but they control America's
elections now for the most part and
Republicans are like oh whoops isn't
that unfortunate too bad so sad try
again next time
um but we can do something about it we
can start filing lawsuits right now to
to protect us for the 2024 election and
we have to real quick let me just I want
to say one simple thing you can do is
win and then once there are more good
people who are in Congress and in the
Senate then they can start actually
pushing those yeah I mean I was I was
arguing with a great conservative
activist online about this and they said
Harmony why aren't you doing this why
aren't you doing that the way that we
change the voting laws in each of the
states is we have to do it state by
state is Win elections win the
legislature and win the governor's race
and by the way that's not enough you
have to have judges on the state supreme
court who are willing to uphold the laws
you have to have all three of those
things and if you have that you can
absolutely go back to the way it was 20
years ago if you want but it requires
that combination if you don't have it
you got to play the game the way it is
and it's foolish to just say I wish I
wish we were operating in this state
under those rules let me take my ballot
and walk in an election day and vote in
person maybe it's snowing maybe I forgot
that's a bad idea if you can vote early
right now my advice and the advice of
most activists is go ahead and take
advantage of that I'm calling it claim
your vote early so that somebody else
can't take it that's the way to go until
we change those laws
the next next couple of years moving
forward I think the most important thing
is ballot harvesting I think when you
look at the polling likely voters don't
matter they ask everybody are you are
you likely to vote are you registered
yes but then all of a sudden the the
numbers don't equal up because they're
going door to door they're ballad
harvesting that's right we have to
hustle our ballots into the ballot boxes
not emotionally appeal with expensive
ads and hope people show up on Election
Day that is one of the reasons why we're
losing I agree with you Tim that it's
important I don't I think the most
important thing is a message of
something we can do as a society we can
create a new industry of graphene are
you familiar everyone drink we can think
of God right essentially a lot of
activists you might say left-wing
activists are concerned with carbon in
the air you can withdraw the carbon from
the air and turn it into graphene so we
can set up an industry where we're
healing the Earth and building the new
material that will be used in the 21st
century is the Epic most epic Building
Material you should tell Kevin McCarthy
about it but let's let's broaden that
let's broaden that and say when they
talk about climate change and they train
use that as a message for elections the
simple answer is technology will solve
all these problems if we if we advocate
for it be it graphene or something it
will solve this problem but then create
a new one where we start to take so much
carbon out that the trees are suffering
and we'll need to balance that out with
countries across the world and create
like a you know a global initiative
sometimes I think he just says graphene
to get a Razz out of people I wouldn't I
don't even want to I just have to maybe
it's just a pathway to seeing a global
initiative I don't know yes you know
I've had a lot of conversations with
Libertarians and anarchists and I feel
like they're revolutionary I'm more of a
reformer I'm looking for
a few wins here and there and and a path
towards success and right now we're
looking at the loss of of free speech
the platforms where we have our
political communication uh political
conversations have been Stripped Away
from basically everybody it's more
apparent than ever now especially with
Elon leaking all this stuff so for me
I'm kind of like harmit you winning is a
huge net net Advantage you take a look
at what happened in 2022 with the
midterms it was still good but everyone
was surprised it wasn't good enough I
think Republicans are still very much uh
it's changing but it was like what you
were saying they want a good message
they think Unfortunately they can stand
on stage to a bunch of good people and
try and convince them why they're right
and then what ends up happening is the
Democrats just knock on someone's door
and say who cares who's right just Mark
the box with the D on it I mean that's
how you have a fetterman uh you know
that's how you have a Katie Hobbs
absolutely empty vessels but it doesn't
matter because the machine will elect
Whoever has a d behind their name now on
our side we're asking people to elect
the same leadership again and again at
the RNC the Senate the house and expect
that things will be different that's not
very inspiring so I know I can change
one of those things I can't change the
other two you think there should be term
limits for a congressman well I was not
in of that view years ago but I've begun
to come around to that I think I think
we should what would be a reasonable
term limit probably 12 years you know
something like that a decent amount of
time maybe two years for senators or
three three terms that'd be two Senate
terms yeah for me one day in and out
that's it oh that's chaos
term limits are not some magic potion
California's messed up and they have
term limits in their state government
term limits are good I think it will
improve DC but it's a lot structurally
more broken than just terms for
administrators but you know I just want
to bring I'm sorry go ahead oh term
limits for the administrative staff
that that's that's a better reform yeah
but again if you move people out of DC
including government agencies people
will not find it so attractive to hang
on to those jobs because in the real
world those are not very attractive jobs
they're not fulfilling and however you
know they get paid pretty well and
there's no accountability that is the
industry that's the industry of DC so if
people lived in America and they were
like hey Bob is looks happy across the
street and Bob has a job at you know
whatever Factory or doing something
useful there's just more mixing it up in
the real world where would you move it
to if you when you go out of DC well I
wouldn't move it to a particular place
but we have all these um swing states
where we need to win them you know
Arizona
um uh you know Georgia uh I mean Texas
is even becoming a swing state
unfortunately Ohio Pennsylvania I would
move it to those places where we need to
win and and just you know we have to we
have the following departments we have
communications we have fundraising we
have political we have digital we have
administrative all of those things could
be like we learn from covid like my Law
Firm at the beginning of covet had one
office I have five offices today I
haven't even visited them but the
offices are running beautifully because
we have telephones we have zoom we have
ways to communicate with each other we
don't all need to be sitting in some you
know decrepit you know edifice in DC so
you're considering decentralizing yes
absolutely this is a huge reform this
cannot be emphasized enough this alone
will give a competitive Advantage worth
tens of millions of dollars to be out of
the Beltway in the place where you have
to win over voters it will humble the
staff you'll hire better people you'll
be out of the kind of because that way
Consultants just can't take an Uber and
walk a couple blocks and get all their
work done and then go to Morton's then
go to K Street I was like no you got to
get on a plane you got to come visit us
in Buckhead you got to tell us why we
got to use your service you're coming
into our culture with our locally hired
people it changes everything instead of
just the same incestuous Washington DC
hiring Carousel Day One my
recommendation of our meat is just say
the RNC DC building is closed we are
going to sell it you'll make like 40
million dollars right there by selling
that building and we're going to open up
field offices in Wisconsin Arizona and
Georgia and we're going to win elections
so so
fundraising in Florida there you go
you've hermit you've been involved in a
lot more than just this yeah especially
with social media censorship and things
like that do you want to just explain
some of the battles that you've been in
culturally and politically yeah sure
I've been a First Amendment lawyer for
almost my entire career now almost 30
years and
um it first came to my attention what
was going on I mean to be honest with
him the first time I got on Facebook I
ran for State Assembly and a young
staffer told me to get on there and it
became fun I got on Twitter when I
became more active in the state party in
California but then what I learned about
the case of James damore James damore
Young software programmer at Google I
didn't know him but he got fired for
saying the shocking truth that maybe we
should be considering in diversity we
should be talking about diversity of
ideas as well and that and then that was
anathema it got him fired and so so his
friends try to find a conservative
lawyer in California in San Francisco
Bay Area who has expertise in employment
law and that was a you know sort of Venn
diagram of one and so I took his case
and we really made that cause celeb we
exposed what was going on inside Google
and you know I can't discuss the details
but the case had a positive ending and
so as a result of that I really began to
look at some of these things then we get
into Communications decency act section
230 social media censorship I
represented a prominent Canadian
feminist named Megan Murphy Megan Murphy
was critical of a transgender activist
uh Jessica yanev in in Vancouver who was
had hadn't transitioned medically but
was going to Immigrant women's homes and
asking them to wax this person's
genitals you know and these women
wouldn't want to do it and then he would
file civil rights lawsuits against them
for violating their rights and Megan
Murphy was banned initially for saying
men aren't women though exactly recently
reinstated by Elon at the time time the
terms of service of Twitter did not make
misgendering a violation of the terms of
service this is an important point but
the Twitter
Illuminati if you will simply
retroactively change the law that change
the terms of service and bounced her
permanently and so I sued over that case
went to the state court in the court of
appeals and the court said sorry
Communications decency act section 230
means their terms of service don't
matter it's irrelevant what they say to
you they can do whatever they want and
there have been other cases Rogue no
Hanley AKA DC Drano another client of
our firm
um
I I have a question for you on the
section two three
so Wikipedia they you know this one
really uh uh lights a fire in me because
the article about project Veritas is
just a fabrication it's it's a whole
bunch of op-eds most Wikipedia of any
conservatives of absolution but it says
at the top of the article from Wikipedia
that's their byline not the not the user
generated content I'm wondering if
there's some some Vector there for for
suing on defamation terms well they have
all these editors and I'm not sure they
fit the definition of a social media
Network so I haven't really deeply
examined that issue but they have
editors who are appointed there it's a
non-profit Foundation
um Wikipedia is a joke by the way if
anybody here you know cites them or
thinks of relying on them I want to give
a special shout out to our friends in
the corporate press who created their
own Wikipedia entry called Thursday
night Massacre because a small handful
were suspended temporarily on Twitter
for 12 hours or so 12 hours and they
wrote themselves an encyclopedia entry I
guess they assume that in a thousand
years Humanity needs to know this
happened to them yeah exactly so look
until we have a republican congress
senate
president and we still have judges who
are willing to uphold things I mean I
keep talking about 2017 2018. we had all
of those things we had the Supreme Court
we had all the branches of government
and then we have Republican congressmen
who love to pound the table and point
fingers at the executives at these
social media companies and then go to a
reception at you know K Street and pick
up checks from them that's that's the
unit party that that people are talking
about until we have elected officials
who are willing to stand up and say
there needs to be a social media users
Bill of Rights that gives us a private
right of action that Communications
decency act 1996 law way before any of
these social media companies needs to be
edited to make clear that it does not
exempt these companies from normal laws
that govern corporations you mentioned
earlier when you were saying uh Twitter
I agree with you also check out the
Manila principles because they've got
six great principles that are on a path
for law internet law but what you were
saying when Megan Murphy was dealing
with getting banned Twitter changed the
law after the fact then you corrected
yourself and said the terms of services
I do kind of see it as a law and I
wonder the law of the corporation sure
should we win a win a corporate social
media Network changes its terms of
services should that go to Congress and
then they've gotta and let them vote I'm
not sure I trust Congress necessarily I
would definitely trust plaintiff's
lawyers more than Congress so I think we
just need a we we need the right to be
able to go into court and prove our case
in court we're gonna here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna take a few super
chats and then in about 10 minutes we're
actually going to go to audience q a I
think we're I think we are cool pretty
sure and yeah so but there's a few
things that I'll bring up we're not
we're not going to get as many super
chess as we normally do because I
clearly I don't even have a computer in
front of me but there was one I saw
that's really good Ty beham says I would
like to see the RNC pledge to repeal the
Patriot Act what are you guys thoughts
on that can I address that yeah
okay
I am certainly the only member of the
Republican National Committee who when
the Patriot Act was passed joined the
board of the American civil liberties
Union in order to try to repeal it wow
okay and it's held against me believe me
every time I run for any office it's
part of it's part of rana's like Oppo
that she's dumping on me I'm proud of
the fact that back in the day I saw that
the government having this kind of power
in the name of National Security was
rapidly going to be wielded against
Americans and there was only one member
of Congress who voted against it was a
Democrat it was Barbara Lee in
California across the bay in Oakland
good for her but those of us who were
paying attention on both sides of the
aisle there were Republicans back then
still supporting the ACLU not today and
including not me for many years but
exactly what I was worried about 21
years ago has come to pass and it came
to pass years ago and we didn't know
about it and so
we should wake up and smell the coffee
the government should never have that
kind of control to be able to read our
emails read our chats treat all of us as
guilty until proven innocent that is
anathema to the Constitution itself but
what if we if we got rid of the Patriot
Act I don't like the Patriot Act at all
but if we got rid of it and then our
government couldn't spy on us anymore
but then the Chinese government could
and would and the British government
would and the Mexican Government would
like would that put us at a disservice
As Americans no I mean I don't really
follow that I mean if if we're allowing
other governments to spy on us we got to
stop that it's not a solution to just
say we should all be spying so maybe the
Patriot Act itself is irrelevant that we
just need technology that's resilient to
spying or we we need a government that's
resilient to pandering to every you know
foreign Innovation I don't know why Tick
Tock is allowed in this country ban it
ban it I love I love this one too
because there's a lot of uh liberal and
Lefty types who are like oh I'm so free
speech I'm in favor of banning an entire
social media platform and I've seen that
from some of the enlightened centrists
too and uh it's it's a foreign-owned
corporation that's manipulating Our
Youth and
it's a spying it it's a patriot it's
it's the Chinese version of the Patriot
Act that we like gullible fools are
willingly allowing onto our device we
could demand that the code is Open
Source before it sets foot on our soil
I mean look I mean for all of a phrased
Elon Musk for his Innovations you can't
do business in China without being
beholden to the Chinese government
that's a fact
yeah by the way when I show up at RNC
meetings I hate to harp on this but I
pick up the water bottle that they give
me that says RNC this is my husband and
I it's our reflex we turn it over what
does it say made in China I give it back
you have to have some principles no no
tchotchkes from China and my admination
Luke what do you think about banning
tick tock
um complicated issue fifth generational
Warfare I think we need more awareness
more people need to be made aware that
every single piece of their data is
being used harvested and weaponized
against them the U.S intelligence
agencies do it the Chinese intelligence
agencies do it uh we need to be I think
we need a Bill of Rights of of privacy
and and Liberty where we could protect
individuals uh privacy I think that's
more important than ever yeah data
privacy in particular this is so so so
important we must treat our data I don't
know exactly we got a lawyer she can
deal with it but it really does need to
fall under the idea of something akin to
copyright law if you produce the data
you somehow have ownership over that
data you somehow have control over that
data because if we're not doing that
then it's getting used yeah there is a
patchwork of laws in different states
that give you certain rights but it's
not at federal law yeah all right let's
read some more I've got Raymond g
Stanley Jr who of course is a is a big
super chatter shout out Raymond who says
Tim crew guest killer show I dig IRL
spreading the different perspectives to
the youth Tim does this mean you're now
coming out out as a right-winger
conservative no just a milk toast fence
that are as per usual but Luke can harp
on the government all day and everybody
seems to get a kick out of that so we're
good and then we have uh waffle Sensei
he says remember when World War II ended
and we decided to create a one world
government in order to prevent falling
into a One World Government
what I love about this one is that uh
Ian brings up the the liberal economic
order which is
on the website of I think the CFR we
bring it up from time to time uh George
H.W bush brought talked about a new
world order there were a few statements
recently about creating a new world
order I'm curious I guess you know Army
you weren't here for the earlier part of
the conversation about the great reset
this International uh I don't know you
will own us nothing and you will be
happy kind of mentality that we're
seeing
I mean my parents didn't leave their
Homeland and bring me here to America
for America to turn into some kind of
socialist Utopia we don't want that and
so in fact most of the people who come
to this country don't want that it's
amazing how many Americans who grew up
here and have all the privileges in the
world have no awareness about world
history or human nature or the brutality
that happens in the name of equality I
agree and that's tough I I every day
you know I think about there's a lot of
people who are not getting accurate
information they're either believing the
lives in the corporate Media or they
just don't care and the question is how
do you how do you convince them you
convince them by being a part of the
solution you homeschool your children
you promote open carry laws you expose
the controlled Intel agencies
controlling social media you get engaged
with the dialogue you show up at your
school boards you get involved where it
matters and I think we are having
victories we are winning in some extent
there's a bigger fight here it is
spiritual as well but it's a fight that
is absolutely incredible to be a part of
and I'm so happy and blessed to be alive
for it well let me let me ask a tough
question how do you guys feel about the
fact they ban guns in this building
no no that's a Phoenix City thing it's a
Phoenix City yes so that's what I mean
like like well no I don't I don't like
it I'm just someone said Charlie are you
not pro Second Amendment turning point
we are here under the regime of the
Phoenix City Council okay just so we're
clear well that's what I mean I mean
would you feel better or worse if
everybody here was was armed
or better
yeah I I'm totally fine with it
I'm coming in and I see they got all the
big security and stuff like that and
there's the signs and I I grew up in
Chicago and I'm just like I'm not going
to live that way I I it's if I want to
be up here and I want to put myself at
risk that's nothing about everyone I
know no that's no reason to take away
someone else's rights I agree but Luke
mentioned open carry laws and I agree
with that which have been uh growing and
developing and we have more gun rights
than we ever had I think especially on
the local level this is a huge victory
that we need to remember that we need to
promote that we need to keep up the
fight with hey why vote Republican vote
Republican for that only one party's
fighting for your gun rights man yeah
[Applause]
well one response
but it's not bump stock Donnie
okay I mean fine but he he's been he was
better on guns than Biden and I mean
look at the record now yeah well there's
that and I I disagree with you as of
right now no because of the laws passed
because of what what Donald Trump did
um and I think on the local level
government actually you know well hold
on Trump did a bump stock thing which I
didn't like but Trump also appointed
Supreme Court Justices that upheld the
Heller Decision which is way more
consequential than some aesthetic
configuration on a gun but what did
Biden do other than just rhetoric Biden
I believe has now directed the ATF and
the FBI to go after purchases Bank
transactions the bank transactions are a
private company but binding does talk a
tough talk but he hasn't done anything
yet he I from what I understand is he's
our he is re-weaponizing the federal
government to go after what they called
operation choke point which is basically
destroying firearm manufacturers in our
country I mean not to mention nothing is
done by a private company anymore if
anything over the last few days of the
Twitter dump says yes do not believe
that anybody is organically doing things
that are taking away your government is
doing that and come on Biden Biden
appointed katangi Brown Jackson who said
she doesn't believe in the Heller
Decision and Trump gave you three
justices that did Heller Decision is the
Roe versus Wade of Second Amendment
everything that we have with gun rights
hinges on the Heller Decision which was
5-4 Biden wants it repealed Trump put
people in office that upheld it and if
it was Hillary in 2016 it would have
been three liberal justices that's gun
rights would have been they would have
overturned cops would never have
happened that's right so many things and
Heller just so you know was the
Washington DC plaintiff that said I have
a right to own a firearm and Clarence
Thomas was the deciding vote and wrote
the opinion and he said yes not only is
the Second Amendment critical for your
safety but you have a moral right to be
able to defend yourself because of the
second amount you guys make very good
points yeah I can see it on some of them
but I'm still mad at Reagan Banning
machine gun and that's really messed up
and horrible that he did that didn't
Reagan do no fault divorce as well
if you want the thought crime it's
Reagan wasn't as conservative as people
remember what do you guys think about
term limits for Supreme Court Justices
I'm against it I don't like it because
the way you're talking about because of
this guy we we saved our gun rights
makes me very nervous so I don't want to
rely on hoping that someone can come in
and save me yeah but I mean this it's
in my opinion even with the ones who
were there for a long time
I like I like the system where we have
to be forced to elect good people to the
presidency so that we aren't just
waiting for the justices to term out
that it does up the stakes for the
presidency but that's okay because
what's at stake is our Liberty and I
don't want them to just be rotating out
and have new versions of them we're
going to wrap up the live portion for
everybody watching at home and we're
going to take questions from the
audience but for those who are watching
at home become a member at timcast.com
because we're going to have that members
only q a up as the members only portion
for tonight so there's still something
there available for you so smash that
like button you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
but let's go around if you guys want to
shout anything out Charlie well first uh
thank you all in the audience for
sitting through all this you guys are
amazing we do what we do because of you
I want to just say a couple shout outs I
want to thank Tim for making the journey
out here this is unusual and it's really
fun we love having you at Turning Point
USA you're welcome at all of our events
this is really cool and exciting uh for
everyone watching at home we do three
podcasts a day if you guys want to
subscribe to the Charlie Kirk Show
podcast if I piqued your curiosity at
all we are
unabashedly conservative but we have
James Lindsay on a lot our meet on a lot
and Tim I think you're coming on the
show later you guys could type in
Charlie Kirk show to your podcast
provider and hit subscribe it would
bless us and if you guys are interested
in Turning Point USA start a high school
or college chapter tpusa.com
yes well thank you Tim for having me
here today this has been a lot of fun I
look forward to joining you next month
as well thank you Charlie for starting
Turning Point USA one of the most
exciting and Innovative organizations in
the country
um if you are a republican since many of
my Republican fellow members are very
triggered at hearing from their voters I
would ask that you perhaps contact
Republican delegates or activists or
committee man or Precinct man in your
state and ask for a vote on the
leadership of the RNC at that activist
level that's been successful in Arizona
in Texas in Tennessee and increasing in
other states so
finally make your views known stand up
and be counted thank you
[Applause]
you know all of you all for coming out I
want to thank all of you for coming to
to America Fest and supporting this
great event thank you Charlie for
hosting it making it work thank you for
everything you do with with
um having me work with turning point and
come do things at turning point it's
been a fun Journey with you guys thank
you Tim again for having me on um thank
you harmeet for running for chair thank
you for that
that is so important that we clean that
up
um since I guess I get to have a pimping
something of my own moment I just
published a book y'all it's called the
marxification of it really good you
should pick it up if you want to see
Ellie stole our education from our kids
in our society that I won't keep doing a
commercial thank you
well I you know you guys I have made
basically proven uh the concept that we
can do this show live so this has been
extremely Epic thank you
where can people find you eating you can
find me online at Ian Crossland but uh
what about you Luke before we go I just
wanted to say uh were war is murder
taxation is theft police uh police are
gangs and politicians or criminals uh
thank you guys so much for for being
here I disagreed with some of you guys
but at least we could have this honest
conversation I really appreciate it you
guys could find me on youtube.com
forward slash we are change I've been an
independent journalist for way too long
if you like this Biden fetterman 2024
shirt which is probably a reality uh you
can get it on the best
politicalshirts.com and because you do
that's why I'm here thank you again so
much for having me everybody who's
watching online thank you all so much
for hanging out stay tuned for the
members only section at timcast.com and
we will see you all then
foreign